hello went welcomed into this video this
is Round recap video for round 11 this
year's title steel tournament before i'm
going job and go for the games of this
round i want to sorry make a little
announcement that the round 12 and very
likely also round 13 videos will not be
released as a video but rather be done
via a live stream so I'm using the
YouTube live stream function and this
will be on the Saturday on 10 p.m.
central european time for p.m. US East
Coast the usual time that also the
mundane live streams are happening and
you will see that on youtube so if you
are youtube subscriber you will see this
live show announced and being part of
your yeah subscription feed um I'm
probably going to do those kind of
things more often i think its interest
rate interesting way to interact with
the audience and the subscribers and
will probably also improve the overall
quality of this kind of video at the end
it will be archived because it allows
for inter interaction questions and so
on at least I want to try that out okay
so we're going to start with the with
the games of this round and I'm not
quite sure about the order yeah like I
usually start with the less interesting
games and work my way up there um it's
not such a clear order this time the
games were yeah all kind of interesting
so um I'm just going to start with
Mammadyarov Carmona just without okay
hey Ron click there yeah Mammadyarov
corona um not that this was the least
interesting game it's just that this
time it's difficult and I'm just going
by my chance okay um this game was a sea
fresa sodium yeah if you would have
given me like 10
15 shots at guessing the opening of this
game prison I probably wouldn't have
gotten it right so Mammadyarov is
surprising Kerwin a little bit by
playing efore in the first place and
then he even goes for them c3 sicilian
which is not at all fashionable at the
highest level and there must have come
as a surprise ready okay I'm corona
plays with 90 f6 and remembered yarrow
goes for a normal set up this e 6 d 6
line against after Knight f6 is one of
the main options for black against c3
Sicilian and something that can be
really heavily recommended for many
players also because it is playable from
various move all this even if you play
to e6 yeah like if you if we go back
yeah we have this c3 sewing but also
this and again after c3 this is also an
option from this move water so you don't
need a separate variation which can
happen if you for example have something
in mind like this to play yeah then if
you play two is six after Knight f3 e63
you will need a difference a zillion and
here I'm a different answer and here the
same thing is usable from 29 f 3 and c
33 and also from to see three okay um
just a little side note them um
Mammadyarov now place the move Bishop d3
and also play this relatively quickly
this move is not at all popular it has
never been because it has a reputation
of not leading to anything and the
mysterious thing is Carolyn or took
which is normal move d takes not before
all this is known and usually white
players yeah don't go for that line
because
after this you get an end game that
looks really not very attractive for
white it's really a mysterious opening
choice member dr of all of a sudden
going for a four and then playing this
some yeah this harmless-looking line
with white skin being somewhat wrong on
d1 and black getting good play with this
active nights sometimes that's how to
get hard to piece together the rationale
behind some opening choices well I hear
white has to be precise to not be worse
and yeah it didn't really work out so
much like here black is somewhat more
comfortable already took that piece and
no black took only four and the black
advantage is pretty clear he's got the
two bishops and he's got that active
night only for the night he will um yeah
he will get traded yeah but the bishop
pair remains and we very often have to
compare the bishops with them or the
extra bishop that the side with the
bishop / has with the night that the
other person has and here well look at
this night his light is worse than the
bishop quite clearly especially if we
compare it now the bishop is on that
fantastic d 5 square and the night on d
2 is not doing very much here White has
problems and my general was really
struggling a lot trying to ya hear trade
some points and the situation here is
very um very it's a very important
crossroads now of the game karana
decides to push that pawn to a3 which is
a difficult decision he also could have
found played Bishop to e7 and just
continue to build up um difficult to say
in the game um it ultimately didn't net
so much
but it's really tough to say if there
should be seven would have been a lot
better black is keeping an advantage
here no doubt about it but now with this
night regrouping to be one it really
felt like white was ya gettin getting
some relief yeah this is a nice little
tactic Bishop takes me 3 4 a 2 so we've
got some trades here until black is
winning a pawn however the problem is
that the b5 pawned is as good as lost
and it's happened after a couple of
moves that this morn really dropped and
why it keeps this active King in the
whole process here black is winning the
Jeep on and we'll see that in we need to
Jeep on but the white bee pollen is very
very dangerous it seems that why it has
enough here for a draw in any case and
with moves like Luke g54 um Bishop c5
the draw would probably be relatively
easy to get with black black really has
to be a little bit cautiously already
that you don't underestimate the beep on
all of a sudden white gets that Queen
the thing is that Corona no playgroup g1
and this was probably an oversight
because there wasn't any reason to go
for what happens next as I said Bishop
c5 if you go here for example um the
thing is after b6 blackhead just take
this this will be drawn you will get the
pawn here and white has no winning
chances here whatsoever this happened
and now funny enough this move is
possible rook takes f8 King takes b6 and
even though the pawn is two steps away
still two steps away the black rook has
a huge problem here there is no clear
way to stop the pawn the way it went
kawana played the best
possible line rook to g5 threatening
this wide covet that and now back so
that rookie one is threatened again 92 I
ever looking at that be one square
brooke d 1 yeah this is the this is the
key thing the night now is attacked if
white protects it infant like this check
Brooksie one saving the day so what why
did is of course be seven yeah and now
black can take the night one gets the
Queen King g7 yeah and this position is
a draw despite what the computer my tell
you I checked it with with engines and
they all give like + 2.5 and this is the
certain well-known weakness very little
weaknesses the computers still have but
one weaknesses that they don't
understand the concept of a fortress
here and black has an easy draw by just
putting the rook on d5 or alternatively
on f5 and nothing ever happens which is
very evident for human as the White King
can never really help in any way and the
black is just sitting there and shuffles
there's absolutely no way forward for
example you can put the rukon f5 porn on
h5 and then play king g 7 h-7 till hell
freezes over very easy draw in the game
um they actually have a not a couple of
chicken gather the game ended here so a
slightly mysterious game and the
mysterious opening my mama y'all played
that very non testing variation um koala
certainly got some chances but
ultimately couldn't break through it
after this oversight group takes f8 um
he was I think we're lucky that he got
away with the drawdown okay the next
game to check is
what are we going to check next okay
let's let's go roughly with the sorry
with them yeah and let's see how
interesting the games were this is ye
against kayaking okay so this game from
the opening already didn't it look so
exciting I've got a Berlin and why he is
playing this rookie one line which has
the most solid reputation within the
Berlin and the Berlin is the kite solid
in the first place this is them yeah the
most conservative way to play it with
white we have this trades on the e-file
and symmetrical pawn structure this
maneuvers Knight c3 md5 it's getting
little life into the position at least
but still we see a position where
everything that looks normal we get a
completely symmetrical pawn structure
and this is very often the most
important thing to check if you want to
know the game um yeah we'll get some
kind of exciting conflict if the pawn
structure is completely symmetrical like
this it's very unlikely that something
exciting would happen in the game we had
bunch of fairly normal looking moves
they both develop their pieces yeah
rooks got connected f4 was an
interesting try by the Chinese player
may be going for f5 we see that after
those moves it is kayaking smooth and
now him um he had the chance to play
here in a very sound conservative way by
playing at five we are keeping the
structure symmetrical
an important point is that the White
Knight is on III in this position and
does not have any quick regrouping to
use e five or or g5 both sides have a
weakness only forward I think the White
Knight is not very well-placed has to it
can try for some kind of very long
regrouping but even if that comes to e5
black has the night back on c6 or can
try to regroup himself and in some way
like this this is a very equal position
yeah white here cannot reckon on much or
anything at all kayaking didn't do that
he played the move Knight to c6 and in
the process I think maybe underestimated
to the white f5 push maybe you also
wanted to kind of still continue to play
a little bit give white give white
something to me I get a fight going I'm
just speculating here because
objectively speaking this doesn't look
so hot yeah what gets there five porn
back now and has clear play on the F
file um the difficult thing for me in
this game is if we go to this position
it is very obvious that white has a as
an advantage he will win the d5 pawn in
the game we had the Queen's he traded it
will win the d5 pawn and has this
pressure on f7 and can be covered and
the difficult thing for the analyst here
with limited time is to give some kind
of statement if white could have won the
game and I'm spoiling things here it
ends in a draw I'm not really sure um
there wasn't a clear moment where and
they have to trust the computer a little
bit there the computer doesn't find
anything yeah it just gives white a
constant advantage of roughly upon which
is kind of understandable because he's a
pawn up
and why it has this pressure however we
have opposite colored bishops and clear
tendencies form pro blockades there for
example here the bishop blocks the deep
on the rook covers this and as long as
this kind of setup is existing it's not
clear what what you do and check I think
it is a draw already but I wouldn't say
it's totally impossible to maybe maybe
someone finds an idea for why but um
Jack this person wouldn't even would
need to invest some time to figure out
if there are some genius maneuver that
why i can use in the game why he tried
quite quite a bit but there was never a
moment where okay i can really could
have lost the game yeah yeah to scroll a
little bit forward check check the
problem is that this point isn't worth
anything yeah it's just on the sixth
bishop is blocking everything and the
age porn is also not check being not
being so dangerous in short order here
they agree to a draw um yeah kayaking
allowing f5 was risky but it seems that
there was probably no moment for value
to UM to get something very substantial
even though I won't rule it out yeah
that someone finds some some great
resource there that engines don't see
immediately or I didn't see immediately
ok the next came to check is Adams Geary
yeah Adams has gotten a winnin yeah
against against kayaking in the last
round very I think he's happy to finally
win a game at this event it still
doesn't have a good result but still and
give reham yeah he needs a win somewhere
to get back into the race um for first
place so we'll see what happens in this
in fact Agee replace a Sicilian and
after Bishop b5 place g 6 cm the
interesting point is that he takes now
with the beep on this variation had a
slightly very slightly dodgy reputation
for quite a long time because it was
believed that white in many cases gets
an advantage in the center that black
cannot so adequately meet however in
recent years is a bit much but maybe
like last 12 years that 90 ever gained a
little bit of momentum and was used
successfully especially by some chinese
players why he for example will see
something of that or we see a game
reference with the chinese prodigy yeah
here black plays Knight to h6 that looks
strange but there is a method to this
madness no seriously night h6 is a good
move Knight f6 is not seen so much
because this line is believed to be
comfortable for Wyatt NY the switching
queer Queen over to h4 sometimes has
Bishop to h6 that doesn't look so hot
night h6 um has a different idea after
see three castles why players very often
went for deform in let's say lets in
15-20 years ago black set up here was
with F 693 night f7 let's say bishop
here d6 this kind of thing this is
actually something that I have played a
bit in blitz chess yeah I played the
Sicilian specially golf for some years
and when they played Bishop be father
sometimes played the set up because it
is an interesting way to play yeah black
has the two bishops for long term ideas
and the very compact sent however white
has more space and probably a slight
advantage
and nowadays however after deform the
way the Chinese players handle this
position is to take and play d5 quite
interesting the idea is set after a five
there's f6 black is immediately
attacking the white center and tries to
yeah open it up for the two bishops
current the results were pretty pretty
good now so why it is probably looking
for alternatives there and Adamson place
h3y a now give you place in a very
aggressive way not f6 not d6 goes f5
they're trying to do something quickly
in the center 'if I've not to have seven
this is the way in the night goes back
into the game and now interesting set up
by by Adams is not playing d for which
looks very normal but place the move d3
in order to answer Bishop a6 with c4 so
he tries to more blunt this bishop in
the bishop on g7 ok d 6 that is a tech
center and white plays e6 this is the
only way to ya to give this give this
setup for white some kind of sting if
you play something like that like just
recaptures and is very happy with these
two bishops especially this Bishop looks
very good black even has this idea
sometimes g5g for very aggressively
attacking the night also note that
blacks development is very very ok and
so e6 far more interesting movement 925
it was taken I'm sorry now it was taken
and and wide went night a form ok the
white idea is pretty clear c5 is hanging
so what did it give you do we played
Queen to c7 yeah so that after night c5
takes the queen is covering the bishop
Bishop age six oops sorry normal
attacking the rook yeah and here um it
seems that Giri is um yeah it's making
us making a mistake he plays rook to f6
and this move played quite quickly um
led into trouble yeah Adams now took on
e5 giving up the exchange however after
the capture 1985 it becomes evident
pretty quickly that white has a very
nice compensation for this exchange the
night years exceptionally strong is
currently attacking this covering this
yeah black basically has to play Bishop
CA that also is a sensible move really
it's it's forced but it's also very
sensible looking the bishop was looking
at this protected porn completely users
and from c8 it supports the rook to
maybe get rid of that very annoying pawn
however now after the exchange sacrifice
Whitehead deform and enjoys a very nice
and dangerous position um after deform
um black has to avoid the move that he
played after which I think black is
close to close to being lost it seems
that you had to maybe take on g4 take on
B to the complications are a little bit
tough to reliably assess but something
like this for example seems playable for
black even though why it has a strong
initiative the same thing is applying
for the capture on d4 after why just
recaptures yeah it's it's definitely um
something that black is not very
comfortable with defending but it's what
he has to do he played the move g5 and
after that I think white um after the
Bishop g5 Queen h5 was a very decent
alternative but why he has a
a huge advantage yeah 26 and the move
now to keep that big advantage however
was very difficult to play the best move
now for Adams is the very yeah weird in
some way 93 now what is the point of
this move yeah white wants to take only
five with the night and it just looks
weird because so many points are hanging
but whatever black takes it doesn't lead
to anything great yeah let's say queen
takes 95 theses I think very yeah pretty
clear that after let's say Luke checks
rupee one why is innocent initiative is
fantastic no or if Queen takes you form
there is a move look to d1 those are the
most difficult ones so slow moves that
have no decent answer not a force a
threat 1 95 for that matter sometimes
yeah what is black supposed to play
after kundi 3 it's really really hard to
tell yeah some bishop move okay what
happily takes them yeah 93 was probably
winning and that is what the computer
gives and this was played by Adams this
is leading to a good position for wide I
mean probably is still some edge but it
wasn't as convincing as 93 yeah here
Geary only has one move he has to play
you for which is not something you you
love to play but you have to yeah here
White has excellent compensation for his
exchange but it is no concrete win let's
say b3 Bishop takes and yeah queen age
for something like that
yeah why it has a point for the exchange
and lots of pressure this is hanging
blacks pawn structure is pretty bad and
the bishop here can get to a fantastic
swear I mean this position is nice for
wider without any any doubt but it
wasn't the best continuation sorry it
was the best cultivation for black white
is better but what what what gear did is
much worse i'm sorry i'm confusing
myself IAM a give me it took with the
queen or deform and after that adams had
a forced win available it's not easy
though he could have played rook to e1
now and this is winning however the
reason why this winning is not so simple
twin takes jack check this is easy i
mean this is this is this yet seen for
sure the problem is after King to have
six it isn't so self-evident how wide is
continuing this he's a rope down so it
is there is need for something concrete
the move is this one Bishop to e3
retreating the bishop attacking of the
queen and it is really not easy to see
from the from the sodding position that
after let's say Queen takes Queen age
seven this attack is overwhelming yeah
there is for example after Bishop here
then got check track and this for
example threatening mate or after two
intakes check out the direct mail
checkmate yeah what else is there for
black something like this check check
check mate also mate yeah but it is not
so easy to see from from this position
and after the move Adams played he's got
nothing
just like that Bishop e3 greene takes b3
before the position is so very murky but
objectively speaking on why does not
have more than a slight advantage from a
practical point of view however this
position is still very difficult for
black yeah his pawn structure is very
bad and white has also threat threats
against Blacks King in fact the way it
went Adams got this rook active check
and manage to pick up this pawn after
rook t8 his sir could have maintained a
pretty nice advantage share with the
move Queen to be seven it would have
been a really good idea the point is
that now after let's say 25 there is
Queen Texas elm and white has one
another pawn in the game he played the
move back did that move and now after
Queen d5 had no way of avoiding the
Queen trade in a sensible way they can
retreat to see three or something and
continue with Queens on but there is no
real point down yeah why does why does
not have any winning chances in this
position yeah so in the game he traded
took a seven and here it is clear that
we are nearing wrong Jack more moose and
here they agree to a draw so very lucky
in a way draw him for a giri who played
a risky set up and then yeah with g5 and
later Queen takes d4 um he gave Adams
huge opportunities to win the game which
were not taken um tense game okay the
next game to check is a lien of roses so
in this game we got a rude felt
and alien off goes for this line with
Bishop f4 oopsie one it has a fairly no
we cannot really say solid reputation it
does have a solid sound reputation but
there are also shall very sharp lines
but also more simplifying strategic
lines the ones that we got here was more
of more one of the strategic ones that
same here we have this straight Quint
xe5 and yeah why does having nice
central controller text the Queen and
black screen now has to go to age five
this is why it's idea now he's going for
that end game where he's got a little
bit more space due to the pawns it has
got the king in the middle already which
can be quite useful because the King
participates in the game already our
blacks kings on g8 however if we assess
White's potential chances to to win the
game getting something more substantial
and we can still be quite skeptical
about that because blacks position is
ultimately very solid yeah he's got no
weaknesses whatsoever no porn weakness
no square weakness all pawns are back on
the seventh-ranked only the bishop has
been feared cat out so if white has
something it is very um yeah min this
kyo-chan 94 check king of two you know
that didn't really need too much that
Tecna tech but M the way this position
works it's just black wants to trade
stuff too yeah organize a little bit
better and get the King into the place
we have seen his new and king of eight
teen gate now and after some mostly look
ed one was played for complete drug
trade yeah so we got this minor piece
ending and in this ending there were one
or two
moments where it looked like yeah um
yeah here we can go a little bit ahead
yeah what is able to take this pawn and
tau think oh wait isn't that trapped but
it is just about working check near here
you see that black is winning a pawn but
the problem is that white has this very
good Bishop that is helping on both
flanks and with white skin getting
active in a position here black has no
way forward white is just going up and
down with this Bishop you cannot move
the night without activating the White
King and also you cannot win the a pawn
so it is really a drawn ending even
though they played this for quite a
while understandably so we're why not
but even with the be pawn to progress
there is no way forward yeah here they
agree to a draw um if we look at this a
little bit earlier yeah black cannot
play this in order to play be too
because they say six pawn so a fairly
solid and yeah anyway logical draw was a
solid opening low risk opening that West
is so ultimately equalized and at the
end it was a draw ok the next game to
check is then really Navarro and I can't
have any promise you that this was an
exceptionally who hired game ok this is
played not the most sharp opening ever
or sharpest opening ever but he will get
a very very very sharp position shortly
so tomorrow goes for see 596 g6 a very
d4 centric approach and yeah here white
to be honest I don't think that this
kind of setup
almost as wide much this fianchetto the
king saud if black goes for c 526 um
yeah he event really has to ask answer
question what are you going to do let's
say after castles Bishop g7 how are you
ever going to put something in the
center difficult to do now you can go c
3 for example he didn't want to do
something like that he went before so
the last time opportunity to play this
he went for admission to seven and now
and play tonight to be three this is the
problem of whites um why it's opening
here you cannot maintain that night on T
for in the sense of a fashion when you
can theoretically speaking play moves
like c3 but that's very very meek and so
the night went back from the from the
center and let's say here these six
castles black a certain define with the
normal moves that say Knight f6 or we
should be sick something like that
Navarro I ever felt that time was
already right for something more
incisive he played h5 going for age four
and why not the nights are over here and
don't defend against the age pawn push
you haven't really played age three to
be ready to play G for you know this was
something that black could have played
for example now f5 for a very murky
position navara had different I da
played Bishop to e6 Queen to d7 and now
when for f5 and this is a move that when
I first saw it I was thinking oh wow
that's a wild move but if you look at
this a little bit more closely you see
that this is actually very very strong
um the weaknesses that are created by a
five at the g5 square I are totally
irrelevant here because there is no
white piece ever going there however the
far more important thing is that the f
one here is stopping any g formal so
that the booth h4 becomes a very
substantial threat and it's very
difficult for white to defend not
already he decided to to capture and
again was faced with the threat note
that white has a hard time here to play
h form as black plays F for anyway yeah
Bishop takes and here this Bishop take
b2 and black will take that rope I mean
absolutely no doubt about that and like
this this for example Knight f6 and
black justice material it's still very
murky but its its material okay in the
game lad 1 d 2 was played and now of
course age for you navara has gotten a
fantastic position here out of the
opening tix and now just develop Knight
f6 neither three the night is coming
over to help on the Kings side but black
can centralize this night now Bishop g5
developing and Bishop c4 just attacking
the rook yeah what is fun various
supposed to be played rookie one he's in
huge trouble and here navara probably
should have taken on f2 just grabbed
their pawn and now return blacks
position he has excellent yeah he's got
um equal material yeah first of all he
has not sacrificed anything for his
position but his position is really
great yeah the night only four is strong
yes a much better pawn structure he's
got the better King blackbaud castle
long while the White King on each two
fields very insecure this position is
probably winning for black what he did
also looked perfectly normal but
amazingly I'm allowed some play for
when really very unexpected yeah he took
on v2 looking completely normal this
move but now fan really has an
interesting defense of concept and very
nice that he found this idea he played
my night B to D to yeah what's happening
here let's look at this step by step if
black and now decides to take the rook
and after Queen takes white is actually
in good shape the rook is hanging with
check and then bishop is hanging this is
something that we can discard
immediately so what is the problem here
hmm this one yet the queen is trapped
that wasn't a blunder by van vida he
sacrificed the Queen and Navarro plate
93 well if you get this offer it's hard
to refuse it even though black could
have played and it's something to take
into account he could have played this
just take the the bishop and now play
this position which is equal material
but very nice for black to bishops still
the better structure white king is
insecure it's very difficult to be so
modest let's say when you can instead
after Nancy three winter Queen okay
takes intakes funny white only has two
minor pieces for the Queen but he's got
an initiative this is attacked and nine
txt six is threatened yeah so this
happened Knight takes 26 and King evade
and white has compensation here clearly
it's not well it's not clear that's
enough but it is obvious that he has
some compensation because the pieces are
very very active and it is very
difficult to say but I think the way it
is played it was very very human
what navara did he played quinta CA the
Queen was attacked Bishop f4 yeah at him
um he played the movie 5 which i think
is um yeah again very human move the
computers want to defend with some yeah
less obvious moves like look 2h7 yeah
something mysterious like like this
which know where human player probably
would ever play I think the movie 5 okay
here the movie 5 is a very natural human
choice and and it leads to an even
crazier materia configuration knight
takes Bishop takes rook takes Knight
takes bishop takes and it said it's
actually difficult to determine what the
material count is yeah why it has three
minor pieces which quite often is
roughly equal to a queen plus the rook
and black has screen into ropes so this
would mean that black is a huge chunk of
material up however the position is
already if you give this to your
computer it's a draw why because whites
pieces are so active that white will get
some sort of Perpetual on the black king
um in them in the game black plate rook
to age seven and here when Vinny already
could have forced the draw with the ship
t6 check um black has no way out of this
many ideas to try to avoid the draw two
liter pretty quick losses King g6 for
example is killed by Apple 26 check
something like this for example is
winning for white even though this is
not a line that is a super obvious for a
human player and what you can see is
that black has a hard time making a move
here yeah don't forget that this is
still
hang the rook something like this just
win supreme um yeah Bishop t6 already
was a draw but when really took 10 8 i'm
not sure if he had seen that it's the
drawer not in the game now White has two
bishops for the for the Queen really
funny but White's um remaining pieces
coordinate quite well and I think it
should be enough to draw which which
also happened all the bishops and
entered and rookie one it's difficult
now to fend off those all those ideas
check check check check check check yeah
and draw a greet yeah there is no way
out of out of the checks at the end the
draw the end of the yeah pretty amazing
struggle a big fighting game where both
sides really did a great job fan really
completely misplayed the opening it
wasn't in a losing position but still
you need to have that toughness to
defend a bad position like this okay um
the next game I want to look at the only
have two games left is to my chef ski
with white against Dingley run ding
Liren I'm sorry for mispronouncing yeah
for this game I don't want to dig so
deep I want to make a couple of general
remarks we have a Catalan opening
channel dingos for that Bishop before
check line which is popular nowadays why
does playing in the most I'm an active
way with Bishop f4 93 never spending a
temple on the cover of that poem
ok if you don't cover it I'll take it
yeah one thing is doing is he's
snatching up on basic labor and keeps
this for the moment for with Bishop a
six in them cause of the game um white
gets very active pieces for his pawn you
see here night over to a three-year
white has a good center and active
pieces forever black get that counter
playing with you five and here and we
see one issue with why its position you
in this position here you you only have
one idea this is what he plays now right
is a pawn down and has to get something
going and this means to take and player
for get compensation in the center what
does have compensation and I would fully
understand if white player here would be
optimistic about his chances because
well it looks nice and that pawn chain
there's activity the bishop is opened up
all this is true yeah and white a
certain what position is okay one thing
however is important to understand in
the process white had to advance his
pawns quite a bit White's King shelter
is seriously weakened and this long-term
can lead to problems blacks King
position is perfectly safe if you want
to compare it yeah white centralized and
one that porn back there on c6 but black
in return got a fantastic night on d3
now legis keeping this active piece and
it's difficult for white to make any
headway material is equal an 11 point
bag but White's play is not so apparent
he's got active pieces active nights
there but it doesn't really get much
yeah there's no nuclear plan that same
now he went for this G form yeah
attacking on the King side I think that
was prompted by blacks idea of pushing
his pawn but with going G form you
weaken the King side and the King
position even more diggers invading the
only three of them with the rook
doubling and white is pushing now he's
gotten the porn back that's nice but
don't forget those pawns cannot go
backwards Black is very nicely
centralized and I think in fact black is
a little bit better because his king is
safe while whites King and not so much a
black has given up on dare to activate
check and around here I want to look at
one or two alternatives again here
Quincy to was possible and this is still
probably okay for in about equal
position we've already had a couple of
trades so the white surgeon named
somewhat weakened King position is not
such a huge factor with all the trades
and this was played in the game also not
not particularly bad rupee aid in Queens
e to the problem is this position is
very uncomfortable to play what has to
look at all kinds of things back rank
issues and invasion of all the pieces
not to reform
and we'll be through why does the pawn
up still but it's very difficult to keep
the position coordinated rookie one
Queen 2 p-5 and probably why it should
have gone now for rookie to try to keep
that and ask like how he intends to um
yeah further improve the position there
are ways to do that hero could be three
four three be three for example White is
still in some uncomfortable situation
but he still should be able to hold it
yeah this was played however night to
deform by Tomashevsky already had time
issues after this and black plays Queen
to before and here this point is hanging
that rook is hanging and that night is
hanging and this is too much yeah now
white is lost it's just like that
Queenie form rook takes me to that pawn
is dropping and all the initiative and
better coordination that black has um
yeah continues to exist f6 final trial
26 now and now mean white has already
already lost him there are simply too
many problems made him yeah this was
played and this do this very quickly but
there was really no way to save it rook
be one it was a nice little shot after
which this is threatened and something
like this drops a full night so windier
for the Chinese number one over if King
Tomashevsky who's really having a hard
time in this mr. namond it feels yeah
like it's not in his best possible shape
but a good win ear for dingo played a
solid game yeah mostly keeping
well coordinated position while white
had some weaknesses and this ultimately
got to him okay the final game to check
is Carlton who you found and the game
you buy the world champion and the best
female player um yeah it was mostly
about one particular position we have to
be perfectly honest there we got a
Petrov defense russian defense by who
you fancy you played this early in the
vent against Kye a koala it was I think
without any problem and the same line
here now is discussed this game as well
with 93 okay normal moose be three they
are not not the most commonly seen set
up but it is something that has been
played before in some games but should
have six white goes h3g for Kim to be a
droopy one all looking completely normal
both sides centralized and so on this
white have any advantage no not really
yeah efile doubled no 94 traded
everything we should be Sam and now the
rules get traded and you really want
them check so ever anything happening in
this game yes made threat but she saw it
yeah of course so well the position is
just equal it's it's what it is but of
course cars and is continuing and tries
the odd thing here and there if anybody
white has a symbolic advantage there
with this active queen but it's not
something that should ever be converted
into a point all this is I think
not changing much check now we see even
bishops traded white has a slightly more
active queen but this is ever going to
be enough to win a game hard to believe
has not much to come with the pause icon
and check it is just very very equal
yeah in this position now we define
could easily have moved the Queen
somewhere yeah for instance screen 37
and then they continue this however she
decided to trade queens and I wonder how
long couple of Mets okay King takes and
now she played very quickly the move h5
um this position here is quite
interesting to look at if you have some
time on your hands and just go through
various possibilities at the end you
will see that here in this position only
one move and only one is drawing the
game White has um winning ideas here
with invasion here and invasion here and
what black has to do is she had to play
the move a five after that it is a draw
for example King before King in six and
there's no way forward if white is
trying some something like that for
example like this before then a black is
just going to ignore that because after
the capture black can stay there is in a
way forward whatsoever for wide if you
as white let's say try to do something
here on the queenside with a six and so
on then king d 5 is happening and you're
going to probably use the camera
then other try after a five would be
like before trying to enter like this
but again black can just ignore that
yeah something like this and nothing
happens if white tries to the address to
take and black is just staying yet the
moon 85 here instead of this would have
drawn the game and it's a very logical
result after like 40 moves off not much
happening yeah but she played age 5 and
the tragic is then after King before
blacks lost it's just losing yeah I
would see in the game why it's very
straightforward way of playing it enters
and now b4 b5 and nothing that black
Hindu had to take twice and King up to
c7 and c3 and here she already resigned
yeah and thing as black is moving a king
goes up in c 6 and this win is very easy
wide will just pick up all the pawns so
what a tragic end of the game and there
was absolutely nothing happening yeah if
we again go back a chant check there was
nothing happening but here that single
mistake of age five instead of a five
costs costs the game yeah it seems that
as I said in an earlier video that who
you found out probably has some problems
with keeping keeping up with those yeah
strong opponents they they have to Dave
round after round and maybe this is one
reason for that lapse of focus in this
particular situation she of course is
totally capable of playing this
correctly but it is it gets probably
more and more difficult after all those
rounds a very important window for
Cardinal is severe
he is on a plus five score now very nice
score and is leading by one point ahead
of Caruana so he has excellent chances
to to win this tournament ok I hope you
enjoyed the video and make sure to join
me on that Saturday live show in the
evening european time you get this
announcement in your youtube
subscription feet ok thanks for watching